A Clockwork Orange, based on Anthony Burgess's novel of the same name, is one
of the best — and most controversial — movies
of the 1970s.
Despite the arguments surrounding the film's
violence, this Stanley Kubrick
picture has become an iconic piece of pop
culture, and multiple directors and showrunners
have since paid tribute to it in their own
works.
So pour yourself a glass of milk as we delve
into some of our favorite Clockwork Orange
Easter eggs.
Hellraiser
Directed by horror icon Clive Barker, Hellraiser
is a horror classic that gave the world Pinhead,
one of the all-time great movie monsters.
The film also contains a Clockwork Orange
reference that's so quick that it's easy to
miss.
In the pic the Cotton House is located at
55 Ludovico Place, which
is a reference to the infamous torture technique
that Alex experiences in Kubrick's masterpiece.
"Well that's good.
I like to video the old films now and again."
Trainspotting
Like A Clockwork Orange, Trainspotting is
also a masterclass of British cinema, and
it includes quite a few nods to Kubrick's
tour de force.
Not only did Danny Boyle design the film's
Volcano nightclub to look reminiscent of Clockwork's
Korova Milk Bar with all the
writing on the wall, but the background music
was played by Heaven 17, a band that was named
after a fictional pop group from the Anthony
Burgess novel.
Star Trek: The Next Generation
In the fourth season of Star Trek: The Next
Generation, an episode called "The Mind's
Eye" featured the Romulans
using their own version of the Ludovico technique.
Since Geordi La Forge is blind,
they have to pump images of violence straight
into his brain, which is somehow even creepier
than what happens to Alex in Clockwork.
"I can tell you've gone to a lot of trouble."
"Indeed we have."
The Dark Knight
While Heath Ledger was playing the Joker in
The Dark Knight, he kept a creepy journal
of all of his influences and thoughts to prepare
for production.
It's probably not too surprising that Alex
DeLarge was a source of inspiration for Heath
Ledger's performance as The Joker — because
they're both sadistic psychopaths who want
to see the world burn.
"Well hello beautiful"
But what might come as a shock is how he managed
to sneak in a subtle nod to Clockwork and
its director with his own version of the Kubrick
stare.
The Kubrick stare is a nod to the fact that,
at some point in nearly all of his movies,
the director has one of the characters stare
at the camera with their head tilted down,
looking up from under the eyebrows, with a
crazed look in their eyes.
It shows up quite often in Clockwork, so it's
probably no coincidence that after being so
influenced by Alex DeLarge, Ledger borrowed
that iconic piece of Malcolm Mcdowell's performance
as well.
Teen Titans
A recurring villain in the DC universe, Mad
Mod is an eccentric fashion designer who uses
his style and technology to brainwash and
wreak havoc.
And in the animated series from 2003 and the
revival in 2017, the character was voiced
by none other than Malcolm McDowell himself.
"Will you ever learn?
You're in my world, my duckies.
You can't win"
To celebrate his involvement, the show goes
full-bore on A Clockwork Orange Easter eggs
during his guest stints.
Mad Mod forces the Teen Titans to watch mind
control videos, and then he also appears alongside
a ton of weird psychedelic imagery that wouldn't
look out of place in the movie that made him
famous.
"Can't have those nasty superpowers disrupting
my legend now can I?"
American Gods
The first episode of American Gods gave us
all the great characters and bloody mayhem
that we've come to expect from TV producer
Bryan Fuller.
One thing fans really liked was the design
of the Technical Boy and his minions, the
Children.
Perhaps the reason they were so popular was
that they were familiar to Clockwork fans
as a nod to the droogs.
Just like the droogs, the Children wear two-toned
jumpsuits and enjoy being silent and violent.
"That's part of the new way."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!